what what none of mine I really don't
know where to go but I guess we can
introduce ourself my name is Pippa and I
have with me a very handsome and tall
very handsome and tall dope fish from
the bleeps yeah and I'm the fat guy I
guess I wanted to be that oh whatever
we're playing the portal deal see that's
release like yesterday yeah like today
see or something new place I think I
don't know and this is pretty much where
I don't recognize how do I show things
yes I guess it's always I thing going on
there yeah I guess we just click on them
there we go whoa it's gonna be another
loading screen probably yes exactly I
guess of course it's a good main course
wait wait so we can't blame them there
we go art therapy oh we can't play them
to disassembly chambers alright exit are
you sure wait where you go maybe we
gotta go there but so no way this is
awesome can I even come back I need you
to be here to press the button why did
he go back wait for me it was like a
door there but no let's go to the exit
oh well this is gonna be like 200 parts
a portal we don't know right okay so oh
man there's a lot of maps it's like 1 2
3 4 5 6 8 times 2 16 oh my god I'm so
good at math yay finally we get to see
the loading screen yes
it took me so long to realize that we
were like the assembler aha that's like
me to disassemble yes you mean like this
yeah Wow I'm faster no wait you're
faster I'm the fat guy you got that mean
that one well I love this [ __ ]
shredding oh yeah it's a Swedish you
have some that is awful no ter insisted
I show you my latest installations well
it's really confusing with this
something about machines only whatever
they they got a Swedish lesson there I
guess got a sign on
[Music]
[Laughter]
they're going to bully me okay
I'm not gonna lie I think most of my
subscribers know that I'm already not
very good at puzzles
hey I can't shoot I can only shoot one
of them oh oh
we only got one yeah it's right I have a
cube what's that button for I haven't
you I have a key oh wait I didn't kill
the robot slave again there we go all
right that's our fancy very all right
get me this picture 31 during laser I'm
not sure okay
I need I need a cube over here okay get
back over nope what do you want put the
bridge back I need it over here I always
need to go with you through my portal
Bridge and lasers that's like easy -
thanks what do you want
give me the cube powder learn how the
cube I was like a little holder here you
press tab you can see it it does not
work no how do i maybe I can kill these
I can so how do I get the cube then why
don't we only have one portal it makes
no sense
Wow oh wait do we have two ports I know
I can only shoot one I promise I promise
you trust me
oh wait I can shoot I can shoot both of
mind oh yeah all right you need to get
it through this hole up here for she
said somehow okay but how can you shoot
too and I shoot one that's not fair you
you probably can't shoot you are you
sure you wait I'm gonna check my voice
keybindings
okay
orange portal on em for whatever reason
oh yeah yeah yeah it was like I figured
this with my girlfriend and she had a
Mac so she couldn't right-click so
that's fine oh okay this right so you
need a place portal oh dear I can't
three over there and then no no no I
know I know
home time I do there I got oh oh you
guys Wow give me the give me the bridge
you want the bridge all right so we
activated oh you need to come over here
oh wait there's there's like robots
there's the robots here again what the
hell can I run past them oh do you think
you need to I don't think you can I
think I need to kill them I need the
relay sir yeah
okay I got the cube
and then now on the make the laser go
through there in there and use the cube
the killer
what should should you portal on me that
way now that won't tell them that yeah
but then you use the cube to direct
laser now Oh can't you do that
it's the wall in the way I don't know ah
okay no I don't me can I
I get the laser over to myself yeah then
it's probably like that you yeah yeah
right
if I have the cube here I can easily
kill them so yeah I need to you need the
bridge yeah
are you sure
I never be sure to share with bridges
same okay no no no give me the [ __ ]
again are you oh god I'm getting stuck
all right now put the laser over here
another shoot it up and go I'm lagging
like crazy
Oh God it's probably my teleporting
around I eyes seeing but where
like they're good today
and here oh yeah there yeah there we go
there we go
I'll be killed by the devil got them
like ah okay good there you kill me and
now I are you put the key over there and
we're good to go yes yes okay so one
what no wait we're not done hmm I don't
really I don't think I can do pretty
much I have a bow I have a goal okay I
can throw the bowl over to your side we
need the bolt or something I don't know
maybe do you want this bowl
sure let's throw it over or not oh wait
no no it's gonna let here go yes nope no
what are you doing I'm sorry do it again
but I have no idea when I was supposed
to do with this but sure I have the ball
[Music]
you might want to make it go through
that thing let's go do that
yeah all right we'll see what happens
here and I'm gonna shoot back to my side
I think I'll place a portable here and
one here and then the ball will shoot
over to my side again and I'll have to
do the same but I think I you know stand
still I don't think you need a ball
anymore I think you can just throw the
way but why did I need it in the first
place we just need to keep the momentum
going I think okay no but I I'm
seriously keeping them all okay no no no
no I seriously need the ball look I the
balls go here oh yeah but how can you
give my way but you need to go through
the field to get there oh yeah it's true
it's true yeah so we need to actually
send it over there and come back to this
side here
all right so portal there portal there
oh yeah that's it
now and then we'll see what happens with
a bowl no you have to move me through so
yeah it will fly over there
and you need to be like I'm gonna catch
it there and then we should you should
be able to catch it if you go okay let's
do it again
don't are me Dean do you what let's do
it yeah okay there we go now you need to
put yourself up okay these son I swear
I'm ready at this time really okay okay
I'm super adding super pumped
and it's flying oh yeah yeah go go go
cookie no that went through the field
bow-bow no I'm sorry
oh I'm seriously super I told you I
warned you before we started I'm not go
to this okay now get over there quickly
where's the ball where's the ball it's
about I got the ball yeah yeah you got a
sixty again [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah okay oh
hi oh hi there I think that deserves a
high-five
come over here you yes I see you you
this is my high five
I don't there we go oh well thanks I've
got the first one down are you sure it's
good good fun yeah are you sure you want
to predict I meant are you sure you want
to continue this with me I'm telling you
it's go get more frustrating this listen
to my instructions
okay so want to go 50 more no wait
saying it backwards yes why not
I mean wow this might be good what is
that symbol I don't even know
oh is that lasers I am you know what
that means it looks looks like one of
those guys from Super Mario what the
hell yeah this light bridges and tunnels
and the more you guys alright Super
Mario in my portal
did you see the tip whoa whoa you go
first
what did you say can I see yeah there's
like this scam that's like Super Mario
with portals oh really
yeah sounds fun okay it's pretty mint it
sounds super neat what do we do I'm just
I'm just moving this cube for the reason
and why not
okay the laser needs to go there yeah
and which is easy enough to do and
there's a beach over there oh wow
progress already like a bit removes a
disruption feel there ah okay then I'll
go through it then yeah cuz I'm so smart
I am so smart
that's an RT okay and then we get the
block I didn't know yeah we got the
block
but the block that's not long since the
light fridge how is that even remotely a
block it's not even squared is X bar can
you things I don't know okay I guess we
do need that but I can't really look
round which is quite annoying uh-huh
well there's pretty much nothing here
huh I don't know all right so we get the
light region oh but how do we get the
laser how do we use this box that's
crashed
and what do you later oh this is you
should use the laser on the other thing
no wait you shouldn't actually nevermind
that's tanga and that light [ __ ] is
useless a place to know where I'd say
damn beautiful I know I don't just say
how do we know there's another laser I
didn't even see that I told you
sorry I'm just loo oh you still don't
know values does
and now that in height is a [ __ ] hey
goods to be on it right and it can't
start right away so that's difficulty
that's impossible have to use the light
bridge yes [ __ ] the laser or yes
[Music]